mais comment vous faites pour faire des
repas à 5 francs en 1980 parce que je
suis très économe je fais très attention
avec M
achats madame Mickel la républicaine de
Barcelone les incarne elle tient le
restaurant le moins cher de France
depuis quand avez-vous ouvert ce
restaurant madame Michel oui le 15 mars
[Musique]
et vous avez quitté Barcelone quand 49
49 c'est le restaurant oui 39 c'est
quand j'ai quitté Barcelone mais au
début de l'année le 25
janvier le 25 janvier de 39 le
restaurant je l'ouvert le 15 mars
1949 10 ans après est-ce que est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire quand vous avez
quitté Barcelone le même jour qu'il est
rentré Franco exactement le 25 avril à 5
du matin il y a 6h il y avait le troupe
qui rentit Barcelone et qu'ils ont coupé
Barcelone avec le reste de la
Catalogne et vous n'êtes plus retourné
depuis à Barcel jamais plus mais comment
vous faites pour faire des repas à 5
francs en 1980 parce que je suis très
économe je fait très attention avec
meschs il y a pas de caspage côté vous
êtes dé habitué de la case
amicel
de tris fois par semaine à peu près ou
et pourquoi vous y venez en
fait on trouve l'endroit sympathique on
mange bien et pas cher c'est combien 5
fr le repas et pour cette somme vous
avez quoi exactement on a un H d'œuvre
un plat garni et fromage ou dessert au
choix et un quart de vin
personne ce qu'il faut dire c'est que le
prix est miraculeux mais elle fait de la
bonne
cuisine très bonne qu'on trouve pas en
brasserie l'pression excellente et puis
mais il y a un secret que j'aimerais
bien connaître parce que même chez moi
je mange pas pour 5 Frans c'est pas
possible je crois qu' faudra que Madame
Mel me donne le secret peut-être que
lorsque je rentre chez moi le soir je
pourrais faire une cuisine pour 5 francs
aussi je vais surtout avant il y a une
gaz d'années déjà je connais donc ce
restaurant depuis 15 ans c'était même
pas le menu à 5 franc à cette époqueel
c'est un menu à 3
fran50 je me souviens de ça ça m frappé
et je reviens de temps en temps comme ça
en souvenir parce c'est toujours une
ambiance curieuse et si étrange on
retrouve des gens qu'on a connu quelqu
fois M autrefis
d'ailleurs c'est spécial tout à fait
spéal nous avons Aché un guide le
conseousous
im
lasenim
directamente
FRR
caninisour pouri
macaronie ça merci à sa
façon je aime beaucoup les étudier tout
ça me mettre en contact avec tout le
monde comment il faisit le chinois pour
vous dire merci çave et moi je le
faisaut jour a
spéci couple je sais pas si américain
anglais parce que j'ai
américain'l je sais pas si voulait dire
qu' parlait anglais si qu'il était
anglaise avait un petit garçon et 11 ans
c'est toujours lamentable et le papa et
la maman et la maman il avait une fille
noir d'un côté et un petit garçon une
are petite fille chinoise alors comme je
l'ai regardé il m'a dit que c'était
adopté la petite fille était américaine
la peti l'autre je dis c'est Coré
chinoise ou quoi m' dit coréen al vous
voyez ce sont des personnes qui ont des
sentiments comme le mien à peu
près ça fait plaisir d'être en contact
comme ça avec tout le monde pour
[Musique]
contct